just fire away
we're so full podcast with felipe
esparza right here
and um no rodrigo
that fool in las vegas didn't even tell
us he was going to go over there
i got a text yesterday i sent him a
picture of um
of um alfred robles and a matchup of um
paulie from rocky whatever man and they
look alike man so
then i asked them where you at they said
i'm in las vegas with edwin someone
but i thought you know that i don't know
he would i thought you know like he was
going to come back
and hang out with us on wednesday i
didn't get a
message like prove this with me i didn't
think that we're gonna be there all week
you know that's something you gotta tell
somebody a week ahead of time hey man
i know you're a lu you're a forgetful
guy the drugs have affected you bad
i'm telling you this morning i'm gonna
be in las vegas
and i'm gonna call you in at 4 20 and
remind you again
i'm going to be in las vegas so we don't
know where the hell he's at
so what we don't we need him here for
the big laugh
don't worry we'll add the laugh track
for him
but if you're in las vegas go check out
uh rodrigo torres he's opening up for
edwin san juan at planet hollywood
it's an event to give away prizes for
the best um
old filipino faith looking person
you gotta make like uh like a ninja face
like a
ninja turtle face because that's
everyone's face and you win a prize
you win tickets to go see the show again
on monday
he does show seven days a week at that
place seven
days a week people okay he's like a
comedian
migraine worker you know they'll get you
somehow he's doing seven days
that means he's working monday through
monday one hour show
with the opening of feature and he has
to live in las vegas
man i don't like that deal i remember
one time um this comedian named eric
griffin had a deal at that haha cafe
he was hosting every saturday for the
rest of his life
for 60 dollars luckily workaholics came
along and
you're gonna do that dump again i
remember one time i started arguing with
the owner from the
haha cafe terry and i asked her man
what's some of that deal you gave eric
griffin
to host sixty dollars a month for a
month of comedy
she goes are you making fun of my club i
said no man i'm making fun of bad
decisions and comedy
anyway so we're back people um upcoming
shows i'll be at december 10
one night only in sacramento at harlow's
nightclub there's only 40 tickets left
for if you're listening to this on
saturday
there ain't no more tickets it's done
harlow's december 10
with toby hicks and maybe rodrigo torres
we decided we're going to take him or
not
since he didn't call in everybody
when you're listening to this show
hashtag
rodrigo college colleen foo
called in fool all right
january 5 through the 8th i'll be in
pleasanton california at tommy t's
that's right tommy tees used to be a
steakhouse
then nobody started buying steaks now
they're just a comedy club
january 14th miami florida at
james night center sounds like a clan
meeting
no but it's a theater james knight
center i'll be a guest
on mike f's tour so i guess i'm going
first
january 21st los angeles california at
the novo theater
formerly the nokia formerly an empty lot
in downtown l.a los angeles california
two shows
was a surprise comedy guest people
surprised so surprised that if i mention
a name i'm gonna give him an extra
thousand dollars so i'm not gonna
mention anything
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding you know you know how
it is all right
atlanta georgia i'm coming back to the
punch line
the lana punch line is the original
punch line people not to be confused by
the place
that doesn't book me in san francisco
the san francisco punchline not to be
confused
by that place a san francisco punchline
who has not booked me since 2012
and i remember i went talking a lot of
[ __ ]
on facebook and twitter about because
somebody asked me how could philippa you
don't get buddha
at the san francisco punchline because
um over there they practice
a thing called liberal racism
where the only book latino have
comedians that that look
happy like el madrigal who's a local guy
from san francisco
he gets booked all the time you know and
um
and cristela alonso you know safe
comedians you know they don't book
comedian like felipe esparza or
earthquake
but i talked so much [ __ ] two years ago
that now they do you get to see jeff
garcia over there now
you get to see willie barcena but you
don't get to see me
why because i took one for the team
people i talked so much [ __ ]
that that girl who books the comedy club
went to go talk to my old agent tim
scally
and ask them how come you don't book
um what did felipe say i don't book
comedian like him and he
responded because you don't so that's
why i'm banned or
or no consideration and then i did a
show
a big ass show when a big-ass show that
started after the sun went down
and it was it was a big show man like a
big show
i don't know the comedians that were
there gabriel um
cristina alonso russell peters
mike ebbs headlined so many big
comedians
um roberts something roberts
dave roberts eric roberts ali roberts
he's the black comics
tony roberts yes he went on a stage and
um
i met the guy who runs the whole show
jeff wills
who works for um the punchline you know
but he's big he's big now
live nation and um i got booked at the
last minute for this show
and they were thanking me philippa thank
you for accepting this show
i know you were busy but i wasn't and um
he said
do you want anything out of this can i
do you a favor i said yeah man
booked with the san francisco punchline
so years went by nothing happened
so that's when i started that little san
francisco punchline felipe as far as a
beef
which is the beef is not where the
people of san francisco or the stand-up
comics
who get booked there you know but i
gotta say something you know what what's
up with that man
i gotta get a television show to get
booked in the show yes i will i do have
a pilot that's being written right now
and
but but by that time i will need to get
booked i probably do a theater
with um not with um the punch lambo with
somebody else so anyway people
you want to start another beef there's
your beef hit up the punch line in san
francisco what's up with
felipe as far as not getting booked
it doesn't really matter no more because
you know what at my level
i'm not burning bridges i'm tearing them
down and adding my own bridge
okay people that's how we do i build
bridges i make bridges
all right enough of that so january 27th
i'll be at the atlanta georgia
punch line and that's it people
that's where i'll be enough of that
thanksgiving was awesome
i was in morro bay california i decided
to stick stay away from black friday
and my family and they were good you
know i don't want to talk politics in my
family even though everybody there
was probably voting for hillary but you
know i don't want to
i didn't vote for anybody because i
can't vote you know you can't vote with
criminal record or you can't vote if
you're not american citizen
even though your wife is american that
doesn't count
but i might could have voted but i
didn't
i would have i don't know i probably
wouldn't i never know who to vote it for
i probably would just pull down
these nuts like everybody else so
we're so full hope everybody had a great
thanksgiving
shout out to everybody who was having a
good thanksgiving a lot of people
had to work i seen those sad faces at
target
man i i took a picture with a guy who
works at target and my head that boy had
a sad
face then he put the photo up on
instagram he said
[ __ ] this place don't shop here
i used to work retail man and let me
tell you man it's not the greatest job
in the whole wide world
i used to my first retail job was at
newbury's
on atlantic square wow damn bro old
school huh
and man i was supposed to beer cat i was
supposed to be cashier of that place
but i ended up being the guy that walks
around with a vest
picking up stuff that people didn't like
put away
like a purse that someone left by the
shoes
or potato chips that someone left by the
bathroom
stuff like that all the walking job fair
people
i tripped on some sayings that people
say man they have no
like they have no meaning nowadays you
know like when people
used to say when something really easy
like don't worry bro it's a walk in the
park
but you know if you grew up where i grew
up you know that's not that's not a real
that doesn't sound so easy man like what
park are you talking about man
are you talking about holland back park
at night
or third street gangs there come on man
that's not a walk in the park
in the daytime or nighttime or walk to
park an echo park in 1996
forget about it bro or a walk in the
park at lake lake at midnight
where everybody was selling pcp i just
made that up i didn't even know they
sold pcp over there they probably did
what some fool oh man we have a guest
today man
long story short in 1991 or 92
i was um sent to i would say i was sent
sent i wasn't i was an ascent i had no
choices
i was thrown into a corner or
it's funny when you get to turn into a
corner
you know there's nowhere to go i don't
know why people like living in
cul-de-sacs because there's no way to go
there either
what happened bro oh man i was pushed
into a cul-de-sac
and what happened i had a choice run and
fight
or jump off the gate and run inside the
fire freeway
okay i live in commerce
[Music]
the city of commerce so i went into
rehab
and right away i got a job in the rehab
cooking because i want to eat because i
remember i met this old vet that i know
inside rehab
he said bro if you ever get hungry make
sure if you ever on the run
get a job at a restaurant that and you
always get to eat there
that way you don't have to worry about
buying groceries to just go back to work
and eat
eat other food so i was there chilling
man and at the rehab
it was like non-denomination but it was
basically a lot of christians and
one muslim and one crazy armenian
and one um mormon that read
from a book called adam i don't know
what that was but it was for
kids of alcoholics so we all were
together
and we couldn't really listen to um
regular music
like krla or k earth
or 97.5 kos you know stuff like that
we have to listen to christian music
but a lot of us didn't have christian
music all we had was one tape
[Laughter]
how we had with one tape and we listened
to that tape
back and forward back and forward
so i got to listen to it i memorized it
and the singer on the tape was some dude
named willy g
and i say all right willy g i didn't
know who willie g
was but i knew who was who i know i
heard of the name
before i was in rehab from the old
veteranos
they used to hang out outside my porch
for hours on friday night man and listen
to all these bug goodies all night
and yell loud quattro flats i don't know
why but that was the name of the gang
but they were yellow gangs their gang
names but i don't know
that was a gang fourth street and they
were these dudes were
man they were in pendleton's man it was
like it was like
living in that movie bloody blood out
but
they were all thugs man and they were
all doing drugs
and they were listening to the oldies
but goodies and they were listening to
the
z midnighters but i thought it was a
midnighters two i looked it up the other
night is z
midnighters with two e's and no g is
m-i-d-n-i-t-e-r-s
so th this guy who i love i used to
listen to
music when these guys were out there
doing dope and
partying and walking like zombies
i would listen to his music now in rehab
too
i never got to listen to a music party
like everybody else
i got to watch people party and listen
to his music and then when i
end up in rehab i listen to willie g and
the midnighters
but in this tape he wasn't singing all
these book goodies
he was um singing um gospel
christian music but it was like it was
tight man it was like
he was like singing and then giving you
a little message about his life
about a little tribute a little a little
biography about his life so he'll stop
singing and then he'll show a little bit
about his life that's something i never
heard before like
that's something that only comedians do
nowadays like they'll tell you a joke
and then they'll tell you where the joke
came from or
usually like myself my job my comedy is
more like
more like um what i heard is just like
what i'm telling you about my life plus
i had a little comedy twist to it
but i started listening to it and that's
all i had so i got to know the songs
and this is one of the songs i heard
people if you look them up on the
wikipedia they'll tell you these were
the
the mexican the chicano beetles of
easterly and we have here the lead
singer and one of the founders
of this band and before introducing i
ran into him at a show i did at the
in the city in um city hall
the chamber of commerce and he was there
to introduce him
and i said what you know 180 here
we're at the same spot two guys
one guy that you know that was sharing
his life to me over the cassette
and um we're here together again
and he knew who i was what she really
makes it more important what more
exciting
i got my my nipples were hard i got the
goosebumps
i got chills i turned into a little a
little girl
or a little a little boy who just made
andrew the giant
and the song started playing again and i
found like wayne's world
where they meet alice cooper i'm not
worthy i'm not worthy
so man we have right here willie g
people
from east l.a salesian high school
a when you talk about man that bad that
the east side the east side sound
when it all started it started right
here man right
left to me right here mr willy g tell us
bro
tell us your story we got listeners all
over the world
we got glenn carlin in ireland we've got
um
cleo in amsterdam over there eating
fries with madness
we got coop the comedian in canada
we got this food right now in saudi
arabia chicago and saudi arabia living
over there
we got we got these two chicks from
morocco
who who are muslim who wear the muslim
dresses
they quote blood and blood out because
they love the
whole latino chicano lifestyle
which you guys started that's very
popular right now
we're so full we got willie g here in
the house
thanks for having me man wow that's a
interesting introduction
interesting my brother cool i had no
idea you were in rehab
yes i was in um live again recovery
homes all right with
pastor juan quijera all right
we were there in saugus we were actually
in um
netga first right there by the ranches
then we got too many people and we
merged with another
that's funny we merged with another
rehab and fresno that he had
it was north and south and we it was the
first time
earth and south got together in a rehab
wow
and yeah it was fun man see jesus can do
anything
anything that's what he does he brings
people together
i can't believe it man like like when
you were talking about um
on your show like when we were lit when
i was listening to this song
you would stop midway and then you would
tell
the the listener which is me and this
was a live
show this this was a live show because
in between the the in between takes um
you will say um
a mic check the levels please
that's what you know or show is really
live people
and no bs you might say oh this show was
live no man if it's a show real life
there's always technical difficulties
and you left them in here um check out
the levels please
so where it all began for you man as a
young child
it began for me in south central l.a oh
yeah yeah i went to school on 34th and
central saint patrick's
little catholic school right there with
my two brothers
and uh it was there that i met
edgar skaggs ron gia southern
and blake madison and we used to sing in
the bathroom
chavalillo singing in the bathroom
because of the echo the best sound bro
like in that show white shadow
there you go when they sing in the
showers there you go
and so that's where that's where it
began for me my my older brother huero
uh frank garcia he was darker
[Laughter]
he was the one that could he he got in
everywhere
because he was wet oh you know it's a
white man's world
and uh he's the one that one day pulled
me in
to the the bedroom because uh he noticed
that i was starting to come home
later and later from school uh because i
would walk through the alley
with the guys from 38th street and smoke
camels and lucky strikes
and so he pulled me in one day and he
sat me down and he was playing the
guitar
and he told me you need to learn this
because i can't play and sing at the
same time
that's what he told me but i heard him
play and sing at the same time for years
but that's what he told me and i learned
this song and i i liked it
so instead of hanging out with the guys
i i'd come home right after school
hoping he'd be home so i could learn the
guitar and sing
and that's what started it off and then
uh blake edgar and rangio we got
together
we were nine years old and we did a
talent show at the alks club
right there on jefferson and central
and we won that was it man i got the
book
nine years old you had one would you
have win uh twenty-fourteen
twenty dollars wow twenty dollars twenty
dollars my five bucks each that's a lot
of money man
it was a lot of my money brother and uh
i uh i remember we went we went to
stella burger
and we bought some chili fries and a
cheeseburger
and then we walked over to dolphins of
hollywood on
vernon and central record store and i
bought my first
78 for those of you that don't know that
was a record
a record it was a record a 78 that was a
speed huh
yeah yeah and uh
78 33 or 45 so 78 is fatter
uh the 78 was thicker thicker huh and it
was
it was huge man it was about maybe a
foot in diameter
you're going to wind it up if you had
yeah if you had a victrola
yeah because that's where you played
them mostly because western auto
uh and pep boys they weren't selling
those little record players yet
zodie's was yes zodie nobody could
afford to go to zodi's
zodia was like best buy back then yeah
yeah
a white front white rod wires they're
competitors
but anyway i bought my first 78 record i
remember it was on the
ember label and it was a song by the
silhouettes
called get a job
so that was that was a and that became
our mantra
get a job
[Laughter]
so as kids we hustled you know and uh uh
i got to do a lot
a lot of shows my brother introduced me
to
a lot of musicians and eventually i went
to salesian high school
that had one of the best music
departments
in southern california headed up by
professor bill taggart
and that's where i met romeo prado uh
the architect of the midnighter sound
and eventually we just morphed
we weren't the midnighters immediately
we were the gentiles
the gentiles in boyle heights right
and boyle heights we're the gentiles
because our drummer
jerry ainsworth right he was an orthodox
orthodox russian jew and every wednesday
when we would pick him up for rehearsal
we could hear his father who was a rabbi
jerry
what's the matter with you hanging
around with those
gentiles they're unclean
and so then we as a dig to his own man
we caught the bed
the gentiles
wow that's where it all began for me
felipe wow man so you perform at
like i remember my wife and i we went to
um
a record store right there and um not
within a record store
it's a bookstore i think it's called the
nightlight or the
or the skylight booster on um on los
feliz area by the movie theater oh yeah
and they have a book there and it's
called down the
in the history of um east side music
of east side and it has all the clubs
that you get performed
at like one of the clubs they get
performing with the cso
the cyo cyo yeah yeah
yeah and then another place in commerce
that people have weddings there now but
that was a hot spot
yeah the little union little union the
little union on goodrich
and good ridge yeah and that ended up a
lot of people have weddings there now
wedding receptions
so what you guys we got um you started
the midnighters and when were the
the big break uh the big break for us
was uh
bill taggart once again the the music
teacher he found out that we were
playing in nightclubs
you know nightclubs you know little
dives along woodyard boulevard and
along atlantic and olympic you know the
paradise bocce's club millies
millies you know on whittier boulevard
and uh
uh lito's courtroom on
an olympic and and he he sat us down man
he got real stern with us he said what's
the matter with you guys man
if your parents find out you guys are
playing in those clubs
they're going to take you out of the
band out of the the school band right
and so he was really worried about that
right and they were underage playing
we were underage bro we were 15 you know
16 years old
uh painting painting mustaches on
you know because you know the lights and
the clubs it's dark in there right
but we weren't fooling nobody you know i
mean but but
we were working right we enjoyed the
work
and get a job so uh what he did man he
came up with this
this this idea man that rock and roll
shows
he says we're gonna we're gonna do rock
and roll shows so every sunday
right at lourdes our lady of lourdes
right down third street
and rowan uh he put on these rock and
roll shows man
all the little local bands right wanted
to be in these shows
and he gave us he actually gave us a
platform the first two years were at
lourdes
and then in 1963
people wouldn't fit in the little
auditorium at lords anymore
he moved it to east valley college
auditorium where we could
squeeze in 2500 people right
and the first big show there was in 1963
and he recorded those shows and
in 1964 the big break came for us
uh we were on that show and we were
supposed to back up cannibal and the
headhunters
and they got stuck in the fog coming
from fresno from the rainbow ballroom in
fresno
and they didn't make it we finished our
set and we're looking in the wings and
and bill taggart's going keep going
they're not here keep going
and we looked at each other we didn't
know what to do you know
high school kids we didn't know what to
do we're looking at each other and the
only songs that we had tight
were the songs that we rehearsed with
cannibal and the headhunters
and one of those songs was land of a
thousand dances and we did it
the crowd went crazy man our manager
released it that week
the live recording of it and of course
kind of when the headhunters came back
we told them
you know and they had already tracked it
they had to put their vocals on it
and they released it as well and it it
became a phenom in east l.a brother
because our fan base cannibals fan base
and our fan base they started calling
all the radio stations
so both of the both versions of land of
a thousand dances
went up the charts together and we used
to crack up about it because we used to
back up cannibal a lot you know
i never knew that i never knew that
because
i knew there was some both i didn't wow
that's good good history right there
they were both released around the same
time yeah yeah and they added vocals to
it
wow and you have been practicing
practicing yeah we used to back them up
uh you know they're not a the
cannabinoid hunters were not a band
they were a four four man singing group
a quartet and so it wasn't unusual for
the bands that were doing the gigs to
back up
yeah the singing groups you know like
the salaz brothers they eventually
joined the jaguars
you know because they needed a band you
know a singer's only as good as this
basketball so start-up brother became
the drag word then
they became tiada later on yeah yeah wow
yeah the jaguars existed
robert's about that or the head was in
that kind of
right no no no that that came way after
that point after hour way after that
you're talking 90s oh 2000
they they came you know uh in the 90s i
remember i remember when cannibal
passed away god rest his soul and uh
they were like like putting a band
together to go start doing
shows right and that's how robert
zappapa
came into uh uh into that group
you know really good drummer i mean they
they're out working
as cannibal and the headhunters today so
um
when wow that's a amazing you have a
little man these kids you guys were like
the
instinct of the neighborhood
funny yeah and because wow 2500 people
yeah not just kids adults too right yeah
yeah it was a mixed crowd i mean
that was the cool thing about what we
did if uh
if we liked the song we learned it you
know like the town i live in yeah you
know
mckendy mitchell wrote that song i heard
it coming through texas on a low-powered
radio station
you could only get these stations like
in the middle of the night for 15
minutes and then
you'd lose them right and and back to
gospel
there you go and so i heard i heard
snippets i heard the town i live in i
heard sad girl
you know and and so i brought those
songs back
um and it's great for us because we we
got to introduce
some great songs to an audience that
maybe wouldn't have never heard never
these songs you know they would have
stayed regional in texas and louisiana
you know so um the town that i live in
is lonely it was written by who
mckinley mitchell and i probably had
only released in that area huh
at first first first and then uh
because we hadn't recorded it yet we
were just doing it doing it live in our
shows
people would go to the record inn or or
to the record rack or dolphins
of hollywood and they would ask for it
right by the midnighters and they'd look
they didn't have computers back then
they had these big old books that pages
were yellow they were so old
and they would open them up right and
try to find to see if they had it in
stock
and they said well we have it but it but
we have it like to be with you
by jokuba and the sextet and they would
play it and they go yeah that's the
sound they say
so joe cuba became very popular in east
l.a because
we did to be with you right so we
introduced a lot of great music to an
audience that i think a lot of
a lot of groups maybe when they never
got oldies but goodies heard
yeah they're oldies now but when we did
them they're new they were fresh
you know they're fresh today i was i i
could imagine that like
here you are like you heard this song on
the way to texas
you loved it but then like was but for
somebody to like hear it for the first
time you know a young young dude you're
a also coming from you it sounds like
brand new it's like you're landing on
the moon again
there you go like you're like you're
bringing it to them and then when they
find out like
that someone else wrote it you start
liking it even more
now yeah because now you like both
styles like when i i grew up
in the 80s and i love ska right i like
to love the specials
on that song of that song guns of
navaroon
and then later on with an adult you know
the internet
i found out that the song was written by
the skylights
in 1966 and it's the same song as guns
are never ruined
but then i found out guns never ruined
the movie yeah
i don't know it was a theme yeah
whatever cool so you do the
the cannonball on the run so man what
happened next um
fame or touring well for us yeah your
dad telling you
i don't get in the house oh bro can you
finish high school
you gotta get a job at sears what's
wrong with you
that was like that would always tell me
like no no no no i said comedy
followed white people yeah all that
lifestyle entertainment
it's not for you we have to work
mexicans have to work
you know we didn't come here to be
actors i think what was cool is it's
like we always worked you know our
parents didn't have to tell us
to mow the lawn or take out the trash
you know if
if if it needed to be done you had to be
done you just did it
you know uh you didn't have to hear you
know very often
wait till your dad gets home i know you
know from your mom
i mean we we worked some time we didn't
know when he's gonna go home we hustled
man we shined shoes we sold newspapers
you know we
we we would buy uh old model a's you
know in compton and watts
from mr pruitt he had a junk yard and he
would call
us you know uh hey i got a call you all
might be interested in
and we'd go buy a model a for 20 15
bucks
we'd bring it home we'd get it running
we'd clean it up
and we would take it to southgate or
downey and sell it to the gavachos
who were making hot rods right for 250.
well not quite that much but you know
50 you know 70 dollars we double our
money or
or better you know and that's that's how
we did we we hustled
that's how we got our first cars tambien
you know i remember my first car
was a a 38 uh
chevrolet businessman coupe it was
ugly it was an ugly car felipe but it
was mine
you know what i mean it was mine man and
i had a car man i drove it to school i
drove it everywhere
who are you oh man i was 13 years old
13 years old driving with a car man yeah
playing pup water football
even right now you could still get other
ladies here
i was the only guy and pop warner
football man
that that that would drive to downey
playground i'd show up
i'd drive there in my car get out i got
a scholarship already
put on my shoulder pads and go practice
[Laughter]
but that's what we did man you know it
was fun it was a
really uh uh a formative period for us
growing up
you know we were in car clubs we had the
band
you know it was really social it was
very social the cyo
was a a launching pad for us really
you know the one on first street and
then the one on on
uh cesar chavez boulevard now brooklyn
avenue
and mott right there the paramount
ballroom tambien was on mars street
armani legion stadium man that was like
the memories of a monkey if you guys
don't know it's a song also
that plays pop dances it was written by
frank zappa frank
zappa wrote that song memories of el
monte and uh
that was a big time man art lebeau that
was a big time
those big shows uh yeah those are big
shows man i remember doing
uh with the midnighters uh and we backed
up little anthony in the imperial
oh wow oh that light oh it was amazing
man they came in from new york right
fresh huh with their fedoras nice
clothes oh
bro cashmere uh
overcoats man with their scarves and
their gloves
and they they sat there they sat there
with us right
they said okay we do this song in f and
he would give us the changes in our
guitar player george dominguez
he already knew the songs right anybody
would play
like this it goes like this and they'd
go yeah
you know so they dug us right we were
ready for them
right and that was a big time for us and
the the headliners that night
uh besides little anthony pears were the
four seasons
shari remember sherry baby
that was them man so that was amazing
brother
that was uh uh uh and you were still
teenagers too yeah for young kids to be
put
in that environment and learning from
these guys too
you know like the area i grew up in
south central you know there's a
a really huge you talked about building
bridges you know building bridges
that's what we did man with don julian
uh don julian and the meadowlarks uh
tony allen uh jessie balvin
este uh richard berry
who wrote louis louie all those they're
all from
south central yeah they went to
jefferson high school that was just a
few
few blocks away our goal is big man i
grew up on 43rd street and long beach
avenue where the red car used to run
cosmopolitan brother i mean you know
downtown l.a
long beach pike you know it was amazing
long beach pike that's where the last
factory is now but back in the days that
that place used to compete with
disneyland for amusement parks
definitely for a quarter
round trip from 43rd and vernon we would
get on the red car the long beach flyer
and you put a quarter in the in the
little box right there the guy would
give you a token
for the ride back awesome 25 cents man
round trip
and then downtown we take the watts car
a little smaller
uh trolley car right into downtown on
six in maine
right there to the depot so what willie
g is telling us right now man that in
they had a better bus system
and travel settings rapid transit
brother they have rapid transit people
we're going backwards now yeah so you're
telling me that
you could go anywhere back then like if
you want to go to long beach
to the queen mary from boyle heights it
could happen
on transportation that's right you had
the art car
the arc vr car that ran through east l.a
right up 6th street
would take you all the way downtown
right and then from there you would
transfer to the
long beach flyer or the watts car and
vamanos a lot of people from los angeles
don't know that we had a a
a trolley system and a subway system
that was working a long time ago that's
right and it was bought by the michelin
tires right yeah
yeah yeah good year and mayor jordy
you know did some deal with general
motors and they brought the diesel
buses in man and contaminated our city
you know and ran it down man uh
contributed to the traffic
congestion you know it's a bad bad
decision
just like uh uh displacing the people
from chavez ravine
you know and bringing in the dodgers
they could they could have put the
dodgers anywhere in los angeles
but they had to come in they could put
it in griffith park that's right
and they took they took uh chavez ravine
there
you know a lot of bad decisions did you
go there the area when you were a kid
no know that area yeah we had family
that lived in charlotte
yeah we did a project with rag cooter uh
several years ago
uh chavez ravina los angeles story and
we got
don tostie and lalo guerrero and we
wrote a bunch of songs
that were uh indicative of that whole
period
you know and uh just to bring back
you know because the dodgers were
thinking of building a stadium next to
uh the staples center
right they're gonna build a baseball
stadium downtown
right there and we began to ask them
well what are you going to do with
chavez ravine
and they were talking about building
these multi-million dollar
gated community homes and we we we shot
them down bro we said you can't do that
man
if you're going to do if you're going to
move the dodgers you need to give that
land
back to the families that were displaced
by the dodgers there were homeowners huh
that's right
you could there's film man of them
dragging
uh oh oh grandma's man out of their
cribs man you know
out of the pads throwing them in the
back of sheriff's cars man
and they end up moving different places
huh yeah yeah
a lot of them you know stayed in the
area frogtown
you know down there the clinton our
family
you know moved over to uh right off of
riverside drive
a lot of them moved down their doris
place down in that area but
but chavez ravine man it was uh it was
country bro i mean it was uh
it was still country compared to the
whole city yeah it was beautiful and
just over the crest right there you
could see city hall
but you had this little like farmland
and people carving out a little bit of
veteran lived there too
man from world war ii came home to there
and and
it was multicultural tambien bro that's
why when i look at old photos i see a
black
asian and latino people living there and
all white people yeah
well you you look at the northern end of
of downtown l.a
a lot of chinese a lot of italian
filipinos japanese
i mean it was it was amazing we grew up
colorblind
so to speak because we grew up around
all this
uh ethnic diversity you know german
uh italian jewish jewish
i mean it was it was amazing man you
know nobody referred to each other as
that mexican family over there they
didn't
you refer to them as the garcias or or
as the the
the orion or the tibidos or the tibidoks
or the gagliano's or the bagliazos
you always refer to them you know in a
respectful manner
and uh you grew up like that we we we
learned how to respect uh
life property values it's cool
so you started going on tour yeah and um
and um all over the country probably all
over the country we
we travel with big tourists with our
little boat tours or
no art leba was regional more west coast
but there was a bigger
a bigger promoter in the midwest how
that was booking all the big acts
there there were several of them um i
couldn't name them all
you know by their names now i forgot you
know
but uh uh yeah there was guys out there
putting on some of the biggest shows you
know and of course if you alan freed if
you went to alan freed
that's the one i was talking about
thinking about because he's the one that
started putting rock and roll on the
radio and he was getting banned
yeah he also was taking a lot of bribes
to put bands on the radio well they
called it they called it paola back then
yeah now they have that here in there in
our late too but it's called
pay to play like before
you could have a you could have a with
four you could be a
you could in order to be on to play the
whiskey to play these places
you would have to be known like you have
to be the doors or
a hot band now you could just have a
bunch of twitter followers
ten thousand and just book the room and
sell tickets and sell tickets
that's all they're doing now that's the
way they do it pay to play you wanna you
wanna play here
they give you a handful of tickets sell
them home sexy
you know i mean we we
we want to play man where's our green
room yeah we want to play
you know so anyway that's showbiz so
you're you're
touring you guys are starting off as
teenagers
hanging out around with people who are
in their late 20s now early 20s
people who who are vices and all that
and it goes back to that movie i saw
with um
little what's that guy the blind guy red
ray charles ray charles
and he goes into a room and then they're
doing drugs
you don't want nothing to do with this
you don't wanna know how to do this rach
that what happened to you
yeah were you guys already smoking pot
no no we we we were
you know i could feel like you're new
towards this like when i started like
going back to doing being a comedian
everything was all new to me again like
oh man they're doing powder i can't do
that that's drugs
what is that what is that on your nose
what do you mean what is that oh man i
got your you know
i just like the way it smells is that
that
how do you get involved something like
that you know you kind of watched from a
distance
right you know uh i i actually
uh you know i i watch guys you know
passing a joint
in the parking lot at the shrine theater
the shrine you know
you're in the circle there you know
because you're you're on break or in
between sets
and so you're hanging out with the guys
right and they're passing it and
i would pass it you know the first
couple of weeks i did that too
and i would pass here i am 22 years old
just passing another joint i'm just
talking and and and so you know i'm
studying them
right because you know hear all these
stories about the demon weed
you know they used to make these movies
you know with the cops chasing these
guys
and 49 mercury's you know they're
turning the corner
i guess yeah and the the the tire would
hit the curb and the hubcap would fall
out
and like 20 000 joints would fall out of
the hubcap you know
who wrote this movie they got for the
hair examiner
[Laughter]
some communist guy anyway but uh
uh we would watch him from a distance
and i would just say you know i don't
see these guys acting all
crazy man you know they're laughing they
they were hungry
they always got hungry stuff like that
so one day you know i just
you know held it and said okay so this
is the way they do it
and then i coughed for about a half hour
wow that was my first date i remember my
first hit
but up till then you know we we never
got high
uh the the the performance itself was uh
was a high there was always enough time
after the gig
you know and then we just drank beer
back then you know country club stout
these little cans
you know they were little little cans
when it was country club style there's
like a malt liquor
you know what they sell in 40s now
back then it was just a little can man
got you buzzed
and it was innocent a lot of it was
innocent you know we traveled like that
we
you know did our show we tried to
maintain
you know our dignity you know and always
put on a good show and
it was always like i say enough time to
party after the gig
and uh we managed to do that for almost
10 years
as the midnighters and uh thanks to the
fans
still today you know they're still
supporting and
following our music art label still
plays us on the art label connection
and you know it's it's uh it's rewarding
it's really gratifying
you know my kids now they inherited uh
my record collection so they know they
know all the artists and the songs and
my son's a great drummer plays in my
band jacob g hey
jacob g what's up fool all right and uh
my son phillips a great guitar player
you know composer both of them both of
them are really really good
my daughters sing but they're they got
kids
but uh it's been a very very gratifying
life and uh 1980 i gave my life to the
lord
after battling drug addiction for
several years
we had cocaine cocaine heroin heroin i
became a heroin addict
and uh this is what happened before malo
or after
this is after malo so you were after the
minute you went to a mallow
right did you start the band and you
just joined the band uh what milo yeah
no no i
i joined the band they were they were
they had been around they had already
done three
three recording projects you know the
the swavasito album
um then those and then they had
evolution
the band was growing you could see that
they were you guys took a lot of
liberties
in your band the midnighters that people
wouldn't do now like you guys were
really hardcore like
you wrote a song called chicano power
right like nobody right here is running
running a star a song called black
power or brow power they're kind of they
kind of want to
we want to cross over what they want to
do but what
what made you guys and then you wrote
that song whittier boulevard
what what what when you guys write that
song chicano power
at that time uh nobody else was well you
know the chicano moratorium you know
with
and then the the riots in the in the 70s
uh uh just prompted us you know we had a
lot of friends that were
in matcha and mapa uh east l.a college
and cal state long beach cal state l.a
very politically minded we weren't
politically minded yet
you know what i mean we knew what was
going on but we always
looked at ourselves as musicians you
know we weren't political
in any degree and uh our pr
our uh recording engineer bruce morgan
his mom she's the one that kind of like
started nudging us towards it
you know cesar chavez was fasting and
going through a lot of
you know to make uh the plight of the
united farm workers union uh
known to people and she says how come
you guys aren't writing songs about
cesar chavez right and and we would go
his name is cesar chavez right so all of
a sudden we we got
chicano you know and uh so she said
y'all y'all ought to be writing about
that guy you know he's doing a lot of
good so we did we wrote a song the
ballad of cesar chavez
and then shortly after that the riots
broke out
on east l.a in east l.a and
we just did a song called chicano power
we just said
you know let's uh let's get in
let's get in with it you know here we
are we can't change our identity
right and now we have a platform where
the midnighters
maybe you know we can be useful you know
to the cause
and uh that's what prompted us to do it
we wrote whittier boulevard almost the
same way because everybody was cruising
people back in the days people used to
get on the lowriders and cruise with
their boulevard like i'm not talking
about it
if you want to watch it live in a movie
some boulevard nights they wrote a movie
called boulevard nights
and um so many other movies but man i
need to drive the cleanest car
and people used to borrow the dad's
pants because of the best lags around
[Laughter]
that and that's how big pets started
right i thought big pants started huh
because
people think that it's a cholo style but
not man it was a necessity
because back then nobody buy it nobody
will buy kids
jeans the way they do now kids nowadays
they could buy
10 12 pairs of jeans when i was a kid i
could pick corduroys
but when um willy g was a kid man there
was no money for kids buy jeans you wear
shorts
or you wear hand-me-downs and if you
want to look good you got to wear your
pubs
clas you got to go in your father's
closet that's right man
and little 100 wool that our mouse man
pleated down
you know and his hat huh oh yeah we used
to we used to
get pops out man put uh toilet tissue
inside so it would fit us
[Laughter]
but we were clean we were clean man and
that's like you say you look back at
some of the old photos of the
midnighters you know
we were always you know pee peen
you know three-piece suits and and that
and we wanted to put our best
foot forward we wanted to really project
an image
you know that wasn't stereotyped you
know and i i really believe that that's
what helped us
cross over uh casey kasem dave hall
b mitchell reed all these disc jockeys
sam riddle
you know that had us on their tv shows
and that they really liked us
because we were versatile you know and
we didn't we didn't project
a stereotypical image you know we
we knew how to blend we knew how to uh
uh
make people happy you know well
one of our first big gigs with uh casey
kasem
and dave hull was the rendezvous
ballroom in balboa island
right here in newport beach yeah right
with dick dale and the dalton
surf music and here we are eight guys
you know uh uh with perpetual
tans and
and the audience looking at us like we
were
space men from saturn or something right
looking at us all weird
but as soon as we struck that first note
and started playing music
they started dancing it was over it was
they were shining that was
it man they they wanted a show for us
home
you know other lady wanted to take it
home it was cool
um other little other liar want to see
willie's g
um yeah casey kaiser says said um
one of his quotes was that you guys were
that the best
band he ever hired ever wow yeah
yeah these guys moving up ten notches is
did their midnighters with um
casey queso man the midnighter had the
best band i ever hired and
i don't know why my wife keeps me in the
closet
was so full so man that's a lot of
partying willy gee
from 1970s to the 60 late 60s to the 80s
and you finally
give up your life what what was your
downfall when you just said oh man
when you said you when you were roberto
duran no mas no mas yeah i just
you know age or the party is not a party
after a while
people don't know that you know
addiction starts off at the party but
later on when you're the only one in the
party it ain't no party no more yeah it
becomes a necessity
and uh i just reached a point in my life
i didn't want to lose my wife i didn't
want to lose
i had two daughters young daughters at
the time uh
very little career to speak of my wife
was working at capitol records and
i really believe the only reason i i
still managed to
carve out a little bit of a life for
myself in the show business was because
of her
you know and uh i i looked at that i
started assessing
my life and things that i'd done and
where am i going what am i gonna do
you know what's next and uh
i really got suicidal and
it was a turning point for me because
while i was trying to get the courage to
take my life a really good friend of
mine tony garcia sax player
from solution high school played in
bands with us in the midnighters
he called me and he's the one he didn't
preach to me nothing like that man
i just sensed a genuine concern you know
he was sincere uh when he asked me
you know how i was doing and i lied
you know i lied about it yeah how great
things were
right and the interesting thing is
felipe
he listened you know you grew up in show
business
most people don't call you to listen
they they can't wait to tell you
about what they're doing right and that
this was interesting to me he listened
he heard me out completely
and then shortly after that he started
uh just following up on me and
he's the one that actually introduced me
you know to the lord
you know him and some of his friends
musicians dishes
yeah so god knew what he was doing he
knew how to how to
hook me in you know and uh march
16 1980 that was a night i went to uh
a prison camp with the with the band the
manny arroyo
orchestra manny or royal orchestra yeah
they were the guys that were playing
nights at all noble they're gonna go
entertain the the convicts right and
they invited me
and i told them that i would go if they
would let me sing
right and so uh tony says yeah bring
your charts man bring your charts
so it was a really great band i really
wanted i said man this
i get another year out of my life with
these guys at least right
and i was blindsided that night man
because i heard my friends guys i grew
up with
you know sharing their experience on
coming to the lord
and it was a an awakening for me
you know i i realized that's what i
needed
you know what else did i i have to lose
in in 30 minutes i was going to be going
back to the same
hellhole i'd been living in for 33 years
you know when am i going to get set free
right they were talking about freedom
liberty you know
new citizenship it intrigued me it all
intrigued me
and then i looked at the prisoners right
and many of them
they had a joy in their faces and their
eyes
they had a piece that i i didn't have
and i was wondering how could these guys
be in here locked up and and
looked like that look happy look you
know and
i found out i was more locked up than
they were
and that's that's a great motivator
there's a group right over there man you
were even though they're
they're locked up and they're smiling
because you were there you were more
locked up
in yourself than these people yeah wow
it's deep man
i felt like that they had a sense of
freedom you know one day they're gonna
get called and they're gonna get
released
they're gonna get paroled or whatever
write probation whatever
but me i'm gonna walk out of there in 30
minutes
right to what back to the same
old same right and so uh
the holy ghost got a hold of me man the
gospel became alive
to me you know i'm i'm a firm believer
that no one's ever the same
felipe after they've been exposed to the
gospel of jesus christ because
the word of god is alive it's powerful
it's sharper than any two-edged sword it
penetrates to the division of the soul
the spirit
the joints and the marrow and is a
discerner of the thoughts and the
intents of the heart
and in those those words you discover
that god knows what's racing
through our minds he knows the burdens
that we carry around
in our heart on a daily basis and
there's a willingness on the part of god
god almighty
to enter into the human condition into
the human situation
and transform it forever and that
transformation process has been going on
in my life for over 36 years well you
must have really opened up yourself
and opened up your heart and your mind
that day yeah because man that's a lot
to take in in one moment
yeah and you still have that joy with
you amen amen
you didn't have that before you walked
in there did you feel like
like seeing them happy doesn't that did
for a while did you feel like damn i'm
gonna go back to my
to my same old rat and start doing more
drugs right now oh yeah definitely
some of the times i felt that way too
man like i see joy
everybody else i remember i did a show
at victory outreach new year's eve
because i was hired by you know him
gilbert esquivel yeah
gilbert esquivel who's a cr a comedian
and
a christian and he had his demon he's
sober
um he and this is true i had no money
that weekend i had no nothing else to do
you know i needed this money just to get
me through
to for three weeks of the beginning of
the year because i know that
after three weeks i'm gonna make another
show and plus this show you know you as
a performer you add your money you know
through these gigs
and um i did the show and everybody was
doing their testimony about how
how long they've been sober and here i
am sitting down
with my legs you know shaking my legs
like we just get this over with
you know i just want to perform and um
and get my money get my money and go
back to my
loft i share with another loser comic
and get [ __ ] up
and i felt guilty the whole time i'm
thinking this because that was a plan
and um and at that moment you know
there was a moment when i was in that
church right there and now
what was that yeah i was in torrance yes
i was in torrance
and i wanted to like if but but i felt
i was just crazy i felt more like a
loser
if i would have stayed there and started
to be clean that night
instead of leaving that night and going
back
to um because i really wanted to i don't
want to i killed that night by the way
everybody listening here i made these
people
laughed and they haven't jumped that
loud since they met the gospel
but by comedy you know made them laugh
you know and um
but the pastor gave me a hug he told me
he he had a guy a guy drove me back home
as a matter of fact because i showed
somebody dropped me off
yeah my wife at the time dropped me off
because she had to go to work she had to
go to work that night
she still had a life you know and
she took time out of her time to drop me
off at this gig
and i had no ride and i remember one of
the
one of the people there um this pastor
had one of the brothers
drive me all the way to the house
and i told him no no no no he just
dropped me off right here
and i knew right there that he knew that
i was not going to go home that night
uh-huh
and he felt bad for me he goes he looked
at me with his eyes like
all right let me pray for you let me
pray for you and he's dead
and then that didn't help and i
ended up going that place wow man so
i can't believe that you were going
through the same stuff that night
same stuff and a lot of times that
happened to you how when you you didn't
care you went back to partying and
oh yeah definitely what made you stay
this time though well
one i i tried to leave i tried to leave
when bobby lawyer and some of the guys
yeah
you're looking for an escape road right
i went yeah i went and sat
way in the back of the cafetorium
right they use it for cafeteria and as
an auditorium there's
joint there at camp affleck right so i
said i'm gonna sit
way in the back so nothing that these
guys say or do
you know or will affect me right that
was the biggest mistake i made man
because as i sat back there with
ancients to leave and
you know i needed i needed something to
go to sleep
yeah you know and and so so i'm saying
there's only one door bro
and that's by the stage where the
preacher was close to where he was
standing right
and i might say no this is horrible and
i should have just sat in front
and so bobby loy i remember he opens a
door
and this guy's preaching preacher didn't
even look at him you know they didn't
pay attention he just stayed on his
thing but i saw bobby and bobby's
looks in the door and he's and then he
sees me right our eyes lock
and he goes like waving me
come come on you know and i went what's
brother you know look at all these guys
you know and and he goes shh like just
real quietly you know just walk along
the wall
you know and all that so i i say oh cool
i'm invisible
right i told myself i'm invisible this
is how invisible i was bro
i'm wearing my favorite emerald green
velvetine pants with the mexican flag
embroidered on it
a flamenco dancer with lightning bolts
and music notes coming off of her heels
and my favorite candy apple red
platform patent leather sandals
the kind you don't want to run out of
gas on the freeway if you're wearing
those
right and all you could hear man as i
got
up this invisible entity now was
walk back was the the platforms
on that concrete floor but i got out
right
and i said what's up what's up foo
[Laughter]
and he says hey some of the guys got to
work tomorrow so you know
we got to head back man uh you wanna
help us load up and
i says yeah can i get a ride back with
you guys and he goes oh yeah
we got a lot of room so man i'm already
loading up the van for these guys right
and
i said i'm gonna get out of here man
right and i go to get in the van
and the guard stops me and he tells me
that i'm not on the list
i go man i'm not on the list man i came
in he says yeah you came in but you came
in
that car with those people and that guy
over there has your idea i said well let
me get mine
he goes nope he goes to policy he
started explaining to me
the whole california penal system policy
and procedure right
right and so i couldn't leave right i
watch my
last my last chance of escape
taillights dimming in the darkness as
they went down the hill
and i'm standing there man i'm just like
looking on
when am i gonna get set free right
and that's when tony tony came out
looking for me man i felt this hand on
my shoulder
he scared the heck out of me man i
turned around he goes what are you doing
out here
i says i was helping the guys you know
he says oh man come on back inside
you know you know and i walked back
inside
and that's when i noticed everything had
changed when i walked
out all these guys were well behaved
sitting there
you know 70 prisoners right or 71
including me
and uh uh most of them
were standing up around the preacher
with their hands up
and some of them were crying some of
them were were smiling and jumping up
and down and i was like
it was like day and night i said what
happened tony says oh the
preacher made an altar call i said
what's an altar call
she began to explain to me that these
guys were going to
ask jesus to be their partner in life
and i never heard that
term right i said that's interesting i
needed a partner
i needed somebody that could help me
make it through right
so i was intrigued by that man and i
didn't even know i was doing it bro
uh tony says when he looked around he he
saw me just
walking towards the crowd with my hands
up
i didn't realize that i was doing that
but there was such a need inside of me
that you know god just
just pushed me over there man said give
it a try
and i did and this type of guy would try
anything once man
if i liked it i did it again right
my addictions were like that mine too
and uh
so that night man i said you know
i gave it a try and i've been liking it
for over 36
years loving it as a matter of fact you
know
it's uh it's been amazing been amazing
god restored my marriage
my kids are serving god we impact a lot
of
youth at risk a lot of families in need
you know in uh
high distress areas we do that i was i
was telling my friend
on the way over here we're under the
radar you know
but but we have a lot of impact we make
a lot of
impact uh a lot of the uh police
departments a lot of social departments
and that
they know what we do and they they
really come to us they they
they come to us to help them in certain
areas and so it's an amazing thing
and i'm still singing and using music
it's a great attraction
music is a great attraction you know we
still going to the
the the projects you know ramona gardens
aliso village
the the vario nuevo the strata courts i
mean
we go we go where the need is you know
where most people don't want to come out
or can't come out for whatever reason we
go to them
amen and you have a show coming up
saturday december 31st uh new year's eve
we're at
new year's eve we're going to be at the
quiet cannon with tierra oh [ __ ]
anyway just come and get dirty yeah get
some dirt on us that night but it's it's
it's it's good it's it's a good good
night to bring in the new year
2017 with lrs exposure i'll be there
with my band doing all the songs you
guys love to hear
sad girl town i live in are you angry
giving up on love with your boulevard
land of a thousand dances i'm even going
to do some of the songs i sang with milo
all right new year's eve that's at the
quiet cannon uh event center there
at 901 via san clemente in montebello
california
you can call 562-254-1609
for tickets vip seating dinners included
65 well that's a deal people
what are they december 31st quiet cannon
willy g for the midnighters
and um and tierra our people let me tell
you right now man
not only you're going to get a good show
for safety father in the dinner
but let me tell you man after the show
right across the street
from the not even across the street from
quite canon on the same side
just park on the side there's a burrito
place called jns yes
that place is good it's a landmark
oh my god you know how it's good because
it's made for people who like to eat
late like sometimes you walk out of a
club
after watching willy g kill it december
31st
a quiet cannon you might say man i feel
like eating a corn dog
and a taco they got it i can't believe
they sell corn dogs at two in the
morning
and they got burritos bro and a pastrami
casavia oh my forgot about
that pastrami quesadilla
we need our pastrami get so big in east
alley man but we have a lot of pastrami
that's right we got tommy's
mm-hmm aries who are you here with man
we got boyle heights page here this is
george um east la.com in the house
so you're helping him promote the show
yeah i'm helping him promote the show
that's funny man um you guys i used to
i used to do comedy and i used to go
with my older older friends to the hop
and the puente you ever do shows there
yes sir i just i used to have a
joke i said i love the hop that's the
only place where you hook up with a mom
and a daughter
[Laughter]
charlie you get big shy girl i get a
little shy girl
so you should do all the big shows i
remember man like
when we used to do i don't need to have
these big
cinco de mayo festivals at boulevard and
bro with your product
with your partner and number when i was
a kid all my friends saw but i didn't
see him there
paul rodriguez performed yeah they
called it la fed yeah la feria right
yeah
it was a big event big event big event
i missed those those like we had and
then um
this this show went on all the way even
to the late 80s right yeah definitely
cause i remember that band was performed
that reggae band they were latino they
they were big at the time
uh uh uh elijah elijah yeah
elijah oh lord have mercy
yeah man he just took me back and now
rodriguez he was throwing um
tortillas to the audience and he goes
hey mexican frisbees
there you go yeah we missed those you
know what they call them now they call
them concerts in the park concert in the
park yeah and they're put on by partners
yeah yeah they have them in san jose too
yeah yeah they have them all over we
we try to work closely with parks and
rec you know because they do
they provide a great service for our
communities but they do that they do
that every summer
and we're doing one uh december 17th at
adventure park
in whittier in the city of whittier it's
a food and toy giveaway that our
ministry does
willie g ministries does every year and
we partner with parks and rec
right there at adventure park
in whittier california december 17th
december 17th maybe we could donate some
toys lisa
yes please yes people donate some toys
december 17
and tell them you're with a whistle full
podcast there you go
wow man because i started doing stand-up
comedy
you know like the late 90s and i met um
rudy moreno he's like easter egg
comedian
and um i remember um he had a comedy
show
on thursday nights at stephen's
steakhouse
and that was the place also that that
was a landmark
stephen steakhouse still around people
okay stephen stephens they are still
around and you guys performed there too
huh
yeah that was a place that was the
hollywood palladium of the east side
that's right
and they still have bands there and
that was a but there was another place
that rudy moreno had with another
steakhouse
on garvey by caddies
oh man i forgot the name of the
steakhouse yeah that's a
that's a victor steakhouse victor's but
that's a little further north for us
yeah we were thinking of the pasta house
the pasta house
yeah i can't believe that you i remember
you used to perform at the
the union oh yeah the big union hall in
vernon city
in an industrial area you know that was
uh
that was that was huge that was huge
when you started off you know with
the sound you know that's known known as
the east side sound right here
was there other chicano bands doing
their own
thing in other parts of the country like
maybe san antonio or
or wherever there was latinos or chicago
yeah definitely you were big in chicago
huh yeah
yeah yeah they really liked us out there
but
yeah the rationales were they weren't
actually from chicago they were from uh
in uh uh michigan but they
you know it's just across the bridge and
not too far but
but also like you mentioned san antonio
meant sunny osuna and the sunliners
the the west side horns you know from
west san antonio latin breed
there's a lot of great bands that came
out of their uh
freddie fender of course sonia osuna
was he is he a skinny man with curly
hair and he he ended up doing radio 2
in san antonio i know no no that's not
the guy
right there there was a guy from el paso
steve crossnow
uh that was a radio personality and
and had a tv show you know and and
i don't think it was his hair i think he
was yeah i think he wore a rug
and you also um i saw you on on a on a
show with
with the east l.a guy big guy
he had to show every uh music show i
forgot his name right now
on local access mr durant robert durant
yeah
yeah yeah mr durant he still does this
show though i think so
i think so he's back backed off a little
bit because of uh
his age and health issues but yeah he's
uh he's uh still a
taste of texas i'll taste the texas of
course i make tacos
taste of texas is another place where a
lot of the tejano bands yeah they would
come in any time little joe
joella familia yeah doug uh the
uh texas tornadoes anytime those guys
were touring it would come through
they would do a show there you play
guitar for gas money
you know keep the bus awesome man get
the bus on the road
so many bad man i wish you had more time
man oh we'll come back
for sure every time you want to promote
a show bro let us know we'll promote it
for you
thank you quiet counting people go check
out willy g
from the midnighters doing the
midnighter songs and some mallow stuff
and tierra that's the salah brothers yes
sir
together together forever that's right
yes what's up let's find something good
to go take us out with
once again thank you felipe for having
us thank you
and george came in all the way from
kansas city
boys kansas city bro i was there i was i
was there last year i performed at the
kansas city punch line wow so next time
i'm there man
we got to get together so we could let
people know i'm going to be there
absolutely it gets freaking cold over
there yeah well right now it is
oh my god bro i don't know how you guys
do it that's just
where they're going right here yeah both
of those guys yeah now how do you like
50. i got five boys all right i know man
i have
i have kids man who are man
cool i gotta get a hold of someone
someday
oh man let's go out with some
midnighters people
thank you see you guys new year's eve at
the quiet cannon
five six two two five four one six zero
nine
tickets
that's uh 1967. every time i give a girl
all the love that i have got [ __ ]
breaks my heart and then
it's such a shame but it's been gone on
for years
why won't they admit it just giving a
little
you can't make ends meet by leaving love
where's my locs
hell yeah have a good weekend december
31st
quiet cannon show some love go check him
out
also thank you very much for my albums
here
hell yeah god bless everybody
let's do a photo now